violence and war the insane root
Tennessee if Isis continues the Russians
are invading Ukraine and the
Palestinians and Israelis continue to
slug it out does that make you feel
gloomy well don't because if you look at
the numbers war actually seems to be
going out of fashion while the global
population is at an all-time high it
seems that we live in the most peaceful
period in human history how is this
possible
[Music]
as of September 2014 there were four
conflicts going on in the world that had
caused at least 10,000 people to die
since January 2013 9 conflicts that
killed more than 1,000 people and 13
that killed more than 100 since January
not really peaceful but consider this of
all the conflicts going on none is an
active war between countries they are
either civil wars or local conflicts
although civil wars are terrible and
caused huge suffering their impact is
usually way smaller than a war between
nations or empires when two nations
engage in war they can mobilize much
bigger forces have access to all of the
state's resources and logistics and
almost to all of the population so why
have we transitioned from wars between
nation-states to civil wars a lot of it
is to do with colonialism and the Cold
War when the Cold War ended a major
driver of armed conflict vanished too
but the breakup of the communist
dictatorships revealed new or old
tensions and brought new conflicts in
the now freed state which often resulted
in civil war much more importantly in
1945 nearly all of Africa much of Asia
and parts of Latin America were under
colonial
by 1990 all but a few islands were
independent but wait couldn't you argue
that what today's multinational
corporations are doing in the third
world is just as bad as colonialism
let's look at Congo it was established
as a colony in 1885 by the Belgian King
an area 80 times the size of Belgium
violence committed against the
indigenous Congolese and the ruthless
system of economic exploitation had
killed about half of the population by
1908 about ten million Congolese were
executed or starved to death
millions were mutilated and traumatized
the economic exploitation of the Congo
remains the top priority and forced
labour never really ceased completely
until the end of Belgian role in 1960
which is not really that long ago so no
colonialism was much worse than a
vulture capitalism is today and it ended
just two generations ago most of the
conflicts that are going on right now
are in areas that 60 years ago were
under foreign control but things are
getting better until 1989 victory for
one side of the civil war was common
while nowadays victories are much rarer
at the same time negotiated endings have
jumped from 10% to almost 40% what about
the rest of the world
why have nation-states stopped attacking
each other there are four major reasons
one democratization the steady
development from autocracy to democracy
democracies hardly ever fight each other
of all the State against state wars
fought since 1900 only a minority were
fought between democracies to
globalization war is just not as
effective at achieving economic goals as
it used to be today it's almost always
cheaper to buy resources on the global
market than to seize them by force
people from other nations are more
valuable to us alive than dead which
overall is a pretty new concept three
war is so 20th century
World War 1 warfare was seen as an
inevitable part of the human experience
and as a valuable tool which you could
use to achieve goals when diplomacy hit
a brick wall today we have rules that
declare acts of aggression illegal and
stipulate that armed force is only
justified in self-defense or with the
authority of the UN Security Council
these rules are still broken but today
it's harder to do so without sparking
opposition and disapproval also we have
an International Court for war crimes in
the Hague and that's a very recent
innovation before
borders are mostly fixed now after World
War two territorial wars are generally
stopped when most countries pledged to
accept international borders and respect
other nations autonomy but is all of
this just an anomaly or are we on the
road to lasting peace truth is we don't
know yet we need a big enough sample to
rule out the historical average which is
about one or two big Wars per century we
just haven't had enough time since World
War two to rule out the possibility that
war is not going away if we don't have
one major war in the next 75 years we
can be really confident that humanity is
changing so you see war might be over
yes there are nasty conflicts going on
in many places but overall things are
getting better and we can make them even
better by speaking up for peace and
democracy
[Music]